- So what's our plan?
(upbeat music)
- Leave it to Disney to
turn something as boring-
sounding as "Investor's Day"
into the content equivalent of Christmas.
From TV shows, new movies,
and casting announcements,
Disney announced a slew
of all things Marvel
to add even more to the
next phase of the MCU.
But what does this all mean
for you and I, friends?
Well, don't worry we're gonna
break it all down for you
right now on The Ketchup.
- Disney dropped an
Infinity Gauntlet-sized mic
when it revealed huge slates of content,
including everything from Lucasfilm to FX
to Hulu, Pixar, and Marvel.
And while we could talk
for hours about the news
from Disney's Investor Day,
today we're setting our sights on Marvel
and three of the bigger
stories from the day,
starting with everyone's
favorite bad boy from Asgard.
- I'm gonna burn this place to the ground.
- Fans Got their first look at "Loki,"
the new Disney plus series
that promises to reveal what
really happened to MCU's reformed villain.
Though Tom Hiddleston's
character died by Thanos' hand
in "Infinity War,"
the trickster demigod
managed to escape his fate
during the events of
the movie's time heist
when his past self grabbed the Tesseract
and transported to places unknown.
Now the trailer doesn't give much away
besides Owen Wilson's
awesome silver fox makeover
as a member of the TVA,
which stands for the
Time Variance Authority,
a multi-verse agency
tasked with keeping
Marvel's timelines safe
from meddling forces.
Now, we don't know where
the TVA is located,
but from the trailer, we're
guessing an alternate dimension
where the sky is orange,
time moves differently,
and the identity of mysterious
1960s plane hijacker
D.B. Cooper may have just been solved.
So look for "Loki" on
a small screen near you
in May of 2021.
- Glorious.
- Though Captain America
has retired the mantle
and shield, the adventure is far from over
in "Falcon and the Winter Soldier."
Premiering on March 19th on Disney+,
Anthony Mackie and Sebastian Stan
reprise their Avengers roles
as Sam Wilson and Bucky Barnes
as they fight some old enemies,
like Daniel Brühl's Baron
Zemo, as well as some new faces
like John Walker, A.K.A. US agent,
played by MCU newcomer Wyatt Russell.
And the team-up is promised to reinvent
some of what we know from the MCU,
but will they be able to
put aside their differences
to fight international terrorists
while keeping up that witty banter?
We shall wait and see.
- God, I hate you.
- Last but not least,
Disney also announced that
it's gonna take another stab
at a Fantastic Four movie.
So far, Marvel hasn't had much luck
at getting Reed Richards and his crew
into the same hall of fame
as the Avengers or X-Men
despite two different takes on
the story in the last decade.
But you know who else needed
three big-screen tries
before making their crossover
into the MCU?
That's right: Peter Parker.
Which is why Jon Watts, director
of "Spider-Man: Homecoming"
and "Spider-Man: Far From Home,"
will be heading up the new film,
and our spidey senses are just tingling.
And now that the Fab Four will officially
be an MCU property under Disney,
we can expect Johnny Storm
to be hanging with Hawkeye
in no time.
I mean, who knows? Maybe
the Hulk and the Thing
could raid each other's closets.
Weirder things have happened.
- I think it's gratuitous, but whatever.
- Disney also announced a
ton of other Marvel news
about "Black Widow,"
"WandaVision," "Ms. Marvel,"
"She-Hulk," "Hawkeye," "Moon Knight,"
and the first animated series, "What if."
Alright friends,
it's time for us to kick
it over to you, now.
Are you excited by all
these announcements?
Are you overwhelmed?
Do you think Disney is biting
off more than they can chew?
Please let us know all
your thoughts and feelings
in the comments section.
I don't know why I just did jazz hands,
but let us know also what
you're most looking forward to
that's coming up in the MCU.
And don't worry, we got
some more Disney updates
as far as Star Wars and Pixar coming soon,
so stay tuned for that.
As always, can't thank you
enough for watching The Ketchup.
My name's Naz Perez, and
we hope to see your face
in the next video.
Bye.
(upbeat music)